uh the i-94 series between the brewers
and the cubs separated by about an hour
and a half but uh boy separated by a
whole lot more in the standings it has
been a lopsided affair as was evidenced
in game one of this doubleheader when
the brewers rolled on three homers
they're looking to sweep in enemy
territory at historic wrigley field well
the guy who's going to try to beat the
brewers tonight has done it in fact in
spectacular fashion alec mills threw a
no-hitter against the brewers last year
cece he's out there to make his
11th start of the season tonight yeah i
mean uh just trying to go out and start
a good game against a team that's on
fire right now she went out and went six
innings with two runs the last time out
so um you know when you make the trade
to the trade deadline team's depleted
you need to go out and have a good start
so hopefully you can do that tonight
he's underway with christian yelich
leading off tonight look at frankie
swindell rizzo
there he is he's a jersey guy
livingston new jersey st john's boy
getting a chance starting to hit for
some power down in triple-a
picking it right there that's a nice
play
and annie let the picture you don't have
to get over there see that jk that's the
worst it's the first place to get it
themselves you ain't got to cover the
base cece
he told me the first time that um his
first start he goes hey i'm not really
good at getting over and so did my
i'm not really
david bodie leads things off
and it's a top prospect on the mound for
the brewers tonight aaron ashby was a
fourth rounder back in 2018. and he
struck him out a changeup for aaron
ashby the first big league strikeout
in the career for ashby no score as we
go to the bottom half of ending number
two
the clubhouse edition of the brewers and
cubs
center right for peterson to strand a
couple of base runners rolling right
along
clubhouse edition from wrigley field
continues brewers and cubs are scoreless
oh this is terrible we were just
starting to get into this and having a
good time with you
at home but we would encourage you to
stick with us because we're hoping that
this is just a short one we have
concluded
rain delay theater brothers taking over
for the starter alec mills who did good
work two in the third innings of
scoreless baseball
rex brothers uh coming out now for the
44th time 41 in the third in the era of
5.01 it wasn't that long ago it was
about half that
but he's run into a spot of bother here
over the last seven or eight appearances
last time out
a couple days ago against the white sox
he fits the scoreless inning so he's
hopeful that he's able to
keep that rolling
back to the top of the order now and
christian yelich pitch pulled on the
ground to first slowly hit schwendel's
got it takes it to the bag and yelich
just kind of jogging down the line at
first and strickland will take over good
to have him back he's been on the
ten day covid il list he was
fortunate that he was in his home of
atlanta when he got that and matter of
fact he and jake cousins both
were able to stay
at strickland's home and continue to
work out apparently he's got a great
facility right there in his home that he
does his off-season training swinging a
miss he strikes him out with a slider
down and in
and it's a strikeout for hunter
strickland
and there's a strikeout so strickland
comes out
firing breaking balls he gets hap and
bodhi back to back and two k's to start
his night swinging a miss
he struck him out with a slider down low
and it's
a one two three strikeout to side return
two down now for escobar
and the pitch lying down the right field
line it's going to get off the wall
and carry him over toward
fargus it'll hold escobar to a single
but he's at first with two outs
and escorts had a productive day at the
plate had that double
back in the fourth inning of game one
had a base hit in the first inning he
went two for four in game one
so three hits on the day for eduardo
escobar now here's rowdy telez
along the first base line steps on the
bag wisdom flat out to right and is only
at that in the first he's over one and
that one drilled in the air out towards
right center that one back and it's gone
patrick wisdom blasts one into the
bleachers out to right center one to
nothing over milwaukee here in the
fourth could swing it about by wisdom
as he lets this ball get deep on him and
that is the key he was out front
in the ball game earlier today but this
one this breaking ball let's get deep
and then it's really an inner third
slider it's not a way
and he just lets it get back to him and
then just puts a swing on it trying to
hit the ball the other way and with his
power he just drives this ball into the
bleachers for home run number 17.
2-2 pitch missed up and in it's full now
three balls and two strikes
and now it looks like
something's going on with curtis
athletic trainer scott barringer is out
there's an injury visit to the mound and
they're gonna take him out
a little bit of a wince here after that
last throw
hugging at his right arm something's
biting in there so he
looked like he kind of looked like that
right forearm a little bit after he
released the ball runner at third and
one out jackie bradley junior is the
batter and bradley
turns one right field that is off the
glove of fargus
will score bradley in the second
this game is all tied up i'm not sure if
fargus lost that ball in the lights but
it looked to be a catchable ball
yes ball's well struck it's inside again
vargas going back
and it looks like he's got a beat on it
he's about three steps from the ivy on
the warning track down the line in that
well
and as he reaches up to make the catch
he just doesn't catch the ball
and still just went out with christian
yelledge coming to the plate yelich
ground ball off the hand of ryan
bradley's going to score ryan will
recover and toss to first david boney
was right behind him and
kyle ryan with that play may have just
cost his team a run now here's omar
narbaez as they'll intentionally walk
willie adamus so first and second
narvaez up the middle of base hit garcia
round third he'll try to score throw is
off the mark garcia scores
rbi single for omar narvaez adamus goes
first to third and the brewers have
runners on the corners and two outs now
for eduardo escobar escobar a line
driving to right that's going to drop in
there for a base hit
adamus will score now they throw behind
narvin is it and he's gonna get back in
there safely so as uh four spot for the
brewers here in the fifth and now here's
rowdy toles the ninth batter of the
inning that's a shot that is through a
base hit narvaez will turn and burn
he'll score and the brewers add one more
to it another two out rbi single rowdy
teles makes it five to one a five run
inning and the tenth batter of the
inning is coming up luis arias who
started all of this with a double to
left center a little soft liner into
shallow center that's going to drop in
there for a base hit
escobar will score teles will stop at
third
and the brewers lead it six to one ureas
with two hits
in the inning
now here is johneshway fargus in a spot
where if he could get a hold of one and
knock it out of the park the cubs would
be down by only one run a little
dribbler right of the mound fielded by
the pitcher he will throw to first and
it is not in time
a run scores infield single james may
fargus
and it is a six to two ball game we've
got drama folks who's lead six to two
bottom of the six the cubs have the
bases loaded and wilson contreras is
striding up the home plate struck
swinging
contreras goes down the cubs leave the
bases loaded hubs are still alive here's
patrick wisdom
and the 3-2 line drive down the left
field line base it's going to go into
the corner duffy will be able to score
rounding third heading home
patrick wisdom has another knock and
another rbi a one-scoring double and
it's six to three here comes the o2
pitch
chopper hit the short adamus two hops
right to him he throws the first in time
and the sweep of this double header is
complete
you